>>Susan: The United States
spends more money on education
than any other country in the
world except for Switzerland,
and yet we still have these huge
disparities in opportunities
between kids, and mostly, it's
based on a student's zip code
or what neighborhood they live in.
It's tied to their family background,
what kind of educational
opportunities are going
to be available to them
through public schools.
We know that we've got a
looming teacher shortage
in critical subjects, and
we're not going to be able
to solve these problems
through traditional means.
The example that I like to use
is in the state of Georgia,
there are 400 high schools and there
are 89 qualified physics teachers
in the state.
So right there, you know that not
all of your high schools have-
can even offer physics, so
how are you going to do that?
I don't know that we're going to
ramp up the number of teachers going
into those high schools,
unfortunately,
so we can offer online classes.
We can offer online physics
class and train teachers
to teach that class online.
And what we're starting to see
is that in states like Georgia,
they're bringing teachers who have
5 or 10 years of experience, say,
teaching physics that may not
want to teach a full load.
They can come back and all
of a sudden have adjunct
faculty positions.
They have part-time
teaching positions,
and they're able to teach online.
Here, you've got a great experienced
teacher that has left the field.
You can bring them back in and give
them new professional opportunities.
And the teachers are
loving it because they feel
like they have more one-on-one
interactions with the kids
in their classes, but it also
gives them some flexibility
in how they teach and a
broader range of kids to teach,
whether it's in that state or beyond.
What online learning does, it
allows you to use time differently.
It allows you to work with every
child individually in how they move-
move through the content and not
just use the time but the support,
the kind of student
support that comes
up with students working
together peer to peer,
students working with the teacher.
When you start looking at these kind
of reform movements that say, "Well,
let's take the existing
school model that we have,
but what we need is a longer
day," I think you're going
to see more kids frustrated.
They don't want to be there
in the same system longer.
They want to do things differently.
They want- they want the relevance,
they want those relationships,
and they want that kind
of critical thinking,
and- and they want to be challenged.
We need to really shift the way we do
professional development for teachers
and just modernize it, and that means
prepare them to go out and teach
in a digital, connected,
collaborative, networked world.
Let's start there.
And then the students that are
coming into these schools are going
to be able to take more
self-responsibility
and be more self-directed because
they know they have to move
through this content and
curriculum by a certain time,
and they can make the choice whether
to take a- a few more minutes
on another project or to make
the choice to not do some work
for a while or make the choice
to go back and do the work.
The work's still going
to be there for them.
Online learning is connecting
people from all across the country,
even all across the world,
with students in every setting
and giving them individualized
learning opportunities,
connecting them with great teachers,
and really tracking how
well students are doing.
So even if they struggle in a class
the first time when they take it,
they can be given new resources,
a broader range of resources,
and we're really starting to see
that students taking online
courses are more engaged and in many
of the programs are having much
higher rates of success in terms
of not just finishing the courses but
how well they learn and learning how
to learn differently
in this new modern age.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to Edutopia.org.